حذر الادمره على تشارلز ريتشارد قائد
القياده الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه ستراد كوم
التي تشرف على برنامج الاسلحه النوويه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه حذر من ان
الصين تطور اسلحتها النوويه اسرع بكثير من
الولايات المتحده ووصف ريتشارد ذلك بانه
سيكون مشكله على المدى القريب وقال خلال
محاضره في الندوه السنويه لرابطه الغواصات
البحريه يوم الاربعاء ونشرت تعليقاته في
موقع وزاره الدفاع يوم امس الجمعه انه
بينما يقوم بتقييم مستوى رضع بلاده ضد
الصين فان السفينه تغرق ببطئ لانها بتجين
اسرع مما عليه واشنط
وذهبت اداره على وصف الصين بانها المنافس
العالمي الرئيسي للولايات المتحده وحذرت
من تطوير بيجين لبرنامجها العسكري
والاسحتناويه في وثائقه تشرح الاستراتيجيه
الدفاعيه والعسكريه للولايات المتحده صدرت
نهايه اكتوبر تشرين الاول
التوتر في شبه الجزيره الكوريه تاتي
تصريحات قيد القياده الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه
بخصوص الصين ما رد الفعل حول ذلك
نعم في الحقيقه الصين لم تصدر اي ردود
افعال حول هذه التعليقات وعاده الصين لا
تعلق على مثل هذه التعليقات الخاصه
بتراسانتها النوويه ولا تعلن عن برامجها
النوويه لكن هناك خلال الفتره الاخيره
العديد من الاصوات بات تظهر في الصين
وتطالب بتطوير طرسانه الصين النوويه في ظل
التحديات التي تشهدها المنطقه في اسيا
والماسك خاصه منذ اعلان الولايات المتحده
منذ زمن همم الرئيس باراك اوباما بتحولها
الى منطقه اسيا والباسك وايضا مع زياده
التوتر في جبهه الجزيره الكوريه في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه خاصه بعد ان بدات بعض
الدول في المنطقه بالمطالبه بالولايات
المتحده بزي التسليح يا سواء همم من خلال
تزويدها بصواريخ متطوره او حتى الاصوات في
كوريا الجنوبيه مثلا التي بدات تطالب ب-
اا تخصيص او البدء في برنامج نووي خاص في
كوريا الجنوبيه لمواجهه كوريا برامج كوريا
الشماليه النوويه وبالتالي كل هذه كل هذا
التصعيد يعني الصين تنظر اليه عن كتب
وبقلق خاصه يعني لو لو في المستقبل على
سبيل المثال اصبحت مثل هذه الدول ثلاث دول
نوويه همم قريبه وبجوار الحدود الصينيه
بلا شك سيصبح ذلك مقلقا جدا بالنسبه همم
الصينيين وبالتالي هم
يريدون همم ربما تطوير اسلحتهم او برامج
في مواجهه كل هذه التحديات لكن كما ذكرت
في البدايه الصين عاده ما تتكتم عن
برامجها النوويه ولم تعلن سابقا انها في
سدد تطوير او زياده تراسنتها النوويه وكل
ذلك ياتي في اطار التحليلات
ومطالبات بعض الاكاديميين والخبراء في
الساحه الصينيه لكن ايضا كما ننظر الى
الانباء المتوارده من شبه الجزيره الكوريه
وفي المنطقه المنطقه مقبله على مزيد من
التصعيد والولايات المتحده ايضا
تزيد من وجودها وتراسنتها وسفنها وجنودها
في المنطقه
نعمين شكرا جزيلا لك